KAYAK.
Search one and done.
>> Laura: LET'S GET EXCLUSIVE
REACTION WITH MY INTERVIEW WITH
CARTER PAGE.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN RON
DeSANTIS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR,
THE FEDERALIST, MOLLIE
HEMINGWAY.
BYRON, LET'S START WITH YOU.
>> SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO GET
ALL THE FACTS OUT OF CARTER PAGE
BECAUSE HE JUST DOESN'T SPEAK ON
BUT THAT POINT WHERE HE SAID, I
CONGRESS, WHICH IS TRUE.
IF YOU READ THE INTERVIEW HE HAD
WITH THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, IT'S JUST ON AND ON
AND ON.
HIMSELF AS AN ADVISOR TO THE
KREMLIN.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE THEORIZE, WE
ARE JUST THEORIZING, HE WAS
TRYING TO MAKE HIMSELF MORE LIKE
AN INSIDER THAN HE WAS.
>> Laura: THAT NEVER HAPPENS
IN WASHINGTON OR NEW YORK WHERE
PEOPLE INFLATE THE RESUMES.
MOLLIE      MOLLY?
>> HE WAS BASED IN RUSSIA FOR A
LONG TIME?
HE DOES HAVE CONTEXT IN RUSSIA.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT A CRIME TO
HAVE THESE THINGS.
JUST SEEING HIM TALK ABOUT THESE
THINGS, IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
A MAN WHO HAS ALL THE POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GOING UP
AGAINST HIM, SURVEILLING HIM.
IT IS VERY MUCH AFFECTED HIS
LIFE, HIS BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS.
WITH HIS LIFE.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT HE SAID TONIGHT?
>> HE IS KIND OF A WEIRD DUDE.
THE FACT THAT HE HAS SENT THEM A
RELEASE ALL THE FISA STUFF!
>> Laura: I THINK HE WOULD BE
WORRIED.
>> IT SEEMS HE WANTS THIS STUFF
TO COME OUT BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING THERE.
BUT BECAUSE HE IS A U.S.
CITIZEN, WHEN THEY WENT TO
SURVEILLED HIM, IT'S NOT JUST
THEIR SUSPICION HE COULD BE
ACTING AS AN AGENT OF FOREIGN
POWER, THEY ALSO HAVE TO SHOW
HE'S VIOLATING A CRIMINAL
STATUTE.
VIOLATION.
VIOLATING?
WE NEED TO RELEASE ALL THIS
INFORMATION.
>> Laura: THIS IS MY HUMAN
REACTION.
I FEEL SORRY FOR CARTER PAGE.
I MEAN, -- I LIVED IN RUSSIA AS
A STUDENT.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE DOING
BUSINESS IN RUSSIA.
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE, PEOPLE
IN SCIENCE AND SO FORTH.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE
BUSINESS IN RUSSIA -- YOU KNOW,
DOESN'T MEAN YOU ARE A RUSSIAN
SPY.
MOST PEOPLE, THE HERE CARTER --
"OH, HE'S A RUSSIAN SPY," PEOPLE
THINK THAT BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THE FAKE MEDIA HAS REPORTED ON
REPORTED AS A KNOWN RUSSIAN
AGENT.
YOU RAISED A REAL INTERESTING
BECAUSE -- IF THERE IS
COLLUSION, HE IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS.
PAPODAPOLOUS IS ANOTHER BIG PART
OF THIS, HE WAS NOT CHARGED OF
ANY CONSPIRACY, HE WAS SIMPLY
CHARGED OF LYING TO THE FBI.
WHAT'S THE DEAL WITH CARTER PAGE
ARE THEY COMPLEMENTING BEING
CHARGED WITH ANYTHING?
>> THE ANGLE I DID BEFORE HE
CAME ON, LIBERALS USED TO CARE
ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES.
ABUSES OF THE FISA COURT, THEY
CAN SPY ON AMERICAN.
HERE THEY HAPPEN IN OCTOBER.
>> THIS IS -- IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CANNOT SUPPLY YOU OF
LIFE, LIBERTY, PROPERTY, THEY
CANNOT RESCUE OR SPY ON YOU
WITHOUT A REALLY GOOD REASON.
IT'S THE CIVIL RIGHTS AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES OF CARTER PAGE CAN BE
VIOLATED, THEY CAN BE VIOLATED
FOR ANYONE.
THAT'S WHY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE CAN TRUST THESE COURTS,
THE CHANCE TO PLEAD HIS OWN
CASE.
WE RELY ON THE GOVERNMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY RELY ON THE
INFORMATION THAT'S KEY.
>> WE SHOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
WARRANT, IT'S OFTEN POINTED OUT
-- THEY DIDN'T PUT THE WARRANT
ON HIM UNTIL HE AFTER LEFT THE
CAMPAIGN.
THAT NOT ONLY GETS HIS PHONE
BACK WHEN HE WAS WITH THE
CAMPAIGN.
PLUS IT ALLOWS THE FBI TO BREAK
INTO HIS HOME, SEARCH IT, PLANT
AND ELECTRONICS WHEN HE'S NOT
THERE.
>> POTENTIALLY OTHER LOCATIONS.
IF THEY IDENTIFY OTHER
LOCATIONS, THEY COULD SURVEILLED
OTHER LOCATIONS.
>> Laura: IS IRONICALLY TALK
ABOUT RUSSIA WHEN WE DO THIS, WE
TALK RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
I WANT YOU TO REACT TO MY
CONGRESSMAN, TO BOTH TREY GOWDY
AND IT WAS, WHO ELSE, NUNES, OF
COURSE, MADE THE COMMENT TODAY
ABOUT THE FOOTNOTE AND REACTING
TO IT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> A FOOTNOTE SAYING THAT
A FAR CRY FROM LETTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN PAID FOR DIRT, THAT THE
FBI THEN USED TO GET A WARRANT
ON AN AMERICAN CITIZEN TO SPY ON
ANOTHER CAMPAIGN.
SAYS.
IT TOOK LONGER TO EXPLAIN IT THE
WAY THEY DID IF THEY JUST CAME
RIGHT OUT AND SAID,
HILLARY CLINTON FOR AMERICA AND
THE DNC PAID FOR IT.
BUT THEY DID NOT DO THAT.
RESPONSIBLE FOR FILING THAT,
OMITTING A MATERIAL FACT?
>> YEAH, OF COURSE.
IF YOU ARE PRACTICING LAW, THAT
GOES INTO THAT.
LOOK, THERE COULD BE CRIMINAL
LIABILITY.
INFORMATION.
I HAD READ THE SCHIFF MEMO.
THEY COULD'VE COME OUT AND SAY
IT.
>> Laura: IT'S A MATERIAL
THE APPLICATION.
IF I WAS THAT FISA JUDGE, I
WOULD BE LIVID.
IT MAKES THE JUDGMENT
POTENTIALLY THE WRONG DECISION.
>> IS THE KEY QUESTION.
WOULD DO IT, NORTH KOREA WOULD
DO IT, AND APPARENTLY WE CAN DO
IT IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> THAT PARAGRAPH IN THE NUNES
MEMO, IT'S VERY CLEAR.
THEY DIDN'T TELL THEM DNC AND
CLINTON CAMPAIGN WAS PAYING FOR
IT.
THEY DID NOT.
>> Laura: 100%